the motivation what to top ten we
believe nation
his Mukesh Ambani and here's my take on
his top ten rose to success joy okay
let's kick it off with rule number one
be courageous
the first lesson is courage nobody has
ever achieved anything big in business
or in any walk of life without courage
of course whenever you do anything big
you do feel a little scared but you've
got to conquer fear to discover the
hidden hero within you with courage with
self belief and the can-do spirit you
overcome any adversity
rule number two find and solve problems
the second piece that I think I learned
is that as an entrepreneur it's very
important to find a problem that you
want to solve that you are passionate
about there is no and this is the same
thing that in fact professor share might
you be CEOs blessed to have enemies
always say that I am NOT going to give
you a list of problems and then you can
go and work on anything you find a
problem and then I will grade you and
the quality of the problem that you find
and then I'll grade you on the quality
of solution that you actually do so the
same rules apply for an entrepreneur
that it's not solving problems it's
first finding problems once you find the
problem right then you solve it rule
number three work hard put on your
running shoes put on your running shoes
but remember
that personal and professional success
is not aspirated but marathon we are
lucky to be living in a dynamic world
where anything is possible but it is
important to remember there are no
overnight successes you will need to be
dedicated single-minded and there is no
substitute to hard work and also
remember that in this marathon of life
is not correct race it is important to
achieve our goals but not at any cost
rule number four serve a higher purpose
my father started reliance with $100
when I joined Reliance in 1980 the
market value of Reliance was 30 or 40
million dollars and in 30 years the
opportunities that were provided by this
country has enabled us to create wealth
for India my father was a big believer
that any business that has the sole
purpose of making money is not worth
doing right business must serve a larger
societal purpose reliance raised all its
money from capital markets and from
individual small shareholders so we have
created a million millionaires just by
investing in Reliance out of ordinary
Indians and that is the process of
creating wealth for the country once you
create opportunity wealth comes also if
you want to know what other Indian
entrepreneurs have to say about building
confidence checking my free 250 for
series link in the description below
it's easy to make a buck very hard to
make a difference you have to work with
people where you feel a bit insecure
that's essential because that means
you're working with people who are
better than you to make changes in any
organization you have to have a measure
of very high persistency rule number
five accept failure failures are normal
right with all the success that one sees
people even in my own case don't see how
many times I have failed before I
succeed so they are just a step before
you succeed so never get disheartened by
failures learn from them but never give
up rule number six
ignore the naysayers fill your years and
minds with melodies of optimism turn out
the critics and the cynics the neediest
people people who say in the Hyosung
time and treat them as noise
cancellation dance to your own music and
take some risks in life because it is
often the risk taker who changes the
course of history who innovates who
creates something the world desperately
needs and contributes to the well-being
of millions of lives remember seven
stretch the envelope you grew up amidst
afterwards where you spoilt as a child I
don't think so not even a teensy weensy
bit no right I really think that you
know for us all four of us myself I need
that the Nina we were a very close-knit
family and in those years right
Papa like spent an awful amount of time
with us while like the business was
being and these are the most difficult
years of growing a business from so you
always found time for his Jersey it was
every Sunday that was 100% devoted to us
what he did is brought the
out of all four of us and you know he
was not the typical disciplinarian or
like he would not spoil like except my
youngest sister Nina but that also
within limits
he always focused in terms of bringing
the best out of him giving you the space
giving you the encouragement and always
like his general view when one of my
take homes over said never have an
inferiority complex never like think
that you know you cannot do it he would
encourage us he would really like
stretch the envelope and I think that
for each one of us in the family and me
particularly like that the whole
relationship like it's something that is
a lesson on a lifelong basis rule number
eight feel empathy empathy means caring
and sharing with every human being in
our organization and the world at large
the more we care the higher we grow as
human beings
I understand empathy as dilky dollop it
is the wealth of your heart the more you
spend it on others the more wealthy you
become rule number nine make memories
today as an Ambani you're amongst one of
the richest people in the country what
does money mean to
you know often I have been asked of
being told that you know you have you're
probably one of the richest in India and
things but I think both location myself
feel that money nor wealth is an end to
itself it's how you use your wealth that
is more important and I tell Mukesh all
the time that life is not about making
money or making wealth life is actually
about making memories because that's all
that you leave behind I think this whole
business current of making memories you
know it's it's such a simple statement
when I think it's profound in saying
that and particularly now after Papa
like the only thing that we have of him
are his memories and they very dear to
us and I think that it like Nita is to
always say this that you know every
moment is important and that's what life
is all about and I think it makes I
understand what she's saying and rule
number 10 the last one before a very
special bonus clip is always be an
optimist and finally an entrepreneur is
always positive he's an optimist and he
proves you know the there are lots of
cynics lots of where negative people
around but an entrepreneur spreads the
positive energy that's really what I
have learnt I've got a really special
bonus clip from Mukesh Ambani how to
have role models that I really think
you're going to enjoy but before that
it's time for the three point landing
questions we've got to move from just
watching a video to taking action your
life or business here we go question
number one who are the naysayers that
you need to ignore in your life number
two what is the higher purpose that you
serve and number three where do you need
to feel more empathy
I really have my father as my role model
and he started off with nothing and one
of the things that he said to me is that
you really don't know
Mukesh what it is to be poor and make
sure that you maintain everybody's
self-respect so when you give people
hold their hand on this basis don't give
on that basis right when you give and if
people hold their hand like this that
means they bless you that's the way to
give and in a certain sense some amount
of anonymous giving or doing things that
change society's doing things that leave
a lasting impact and even if it be
creation of businesses creation of jobs
like creation of sustainable
institutions that lasts beyond you is
the best way that you can contribute to
India
if you like this video check out the top
10 idea on Ratan Tata the link is right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
far more is gained by walking on the
shop floor and talking to the people in
trying to communicate one of my
weaknesses has been a thing